今天我們來聊一個很有趣的能源創新，它可能跟我們一般理解的發電方式很不一樣。你可能沒想到，家裡的電器、電動車，甚至儲能系統，竟然能集合起來變成一個「虛擬電廠」。
虛擬電廠？聽起來有點像科幻片的情節。我的恆溫器、電動車、家裡的空調，怎麼會變成電廠？這中間的連接點是什麼？
對，這就是出乎意料的地方。傳統上，我們想到的電廠都是那種巨大的集中式發電廠。但這個創新，它反而是把這些看似零散的家庭設備，透過平台化和智能化的方式聚合起來。
所以這些設備是各自發電嗎？還是說，它們是扮演一個更像是「調整電力需求」的角色？
後者居多。原文提到，這些虛擬電廠（VPP）主要是讓電力公司在用電高峰時段，可以控制這些設備減少耗電。比如說，調高一點你的恆溫器溫度，或是延遲一下電動車充電的時間。
嗯，聽起來就像是「我暫時少用一點電，幫忙電網舒緩壓力」。那對我來說有什麼好處？電力公司為什麼要這樣做？
好處就是回饋。電力公司會給你電費折扣，有些甚至有簽約獎金。EnergyHub 的執行長Seth Frader-Thompson提到，智能恆溫器計畫，初期可能有50到150美元的獎金，每年還有25到50美元。而家庭電池和電動車設備，每年甚至能省下數百到上千美元。
幾百塊到上千塊美元，聽起來不無小補。但這樣一點點減少用電量，真的能起到「發電廠」那麼大的作用嗎？
這就是重點了。單一家庭減少的電量當然不大，但原文強調，Frader-Thompson說「當你把數十萬、數百萬個家庭聚合起來，它就能產生非常深遠的影響」，效應等同於「啟動一座發電廠」。
數百萬個家庭……這規模確實不小。不過，這些虛擬電廠真的普及了嗎？還是說只是一個實驗性的概念？
其實這已經在發展中。原文寫道，截至2023年，光是美國就有超過500個虛擬電廠計畫在運作。甚至Google也開始投資這項技術，用來支援他們資料中心的電力需求。去年，大約有400萬戶安裝了智能恆溫器的家庭，已經參與了這類計畫。
哇，400萬戶！這個數字有點驚人。那對於我們這些一般中小企業主來說，這個案例有什麼啟發？我們又不是電力公司，也不能控制大家的電器。
我覺得，它提醒我們去思考「分散式資源的聚合」。就像這裡把零散的家庭電器聚合起來，創造出一個大型電廠的價值。如果你是開餐廳的，是不是可以思考，怎麼把一些閒置時間或特定資源，例如外送夥伴的閒置時間、店內的閒置空間，透過一個平台聚合起來，創造額外服務？
這麼說好像有點道理。比如我的店面下午茶時段人少，或許可以讓給一些手作坊來開課，既活用空間，也能增加店面曝光。
對，或是對於物流業來說，可能可以思考，配送車輛在回程時通常是空的，如果能串接小型貨物的臨時寄送需求，這就是一種「虛擬車隊」的概念。又或是自由工作者，他們的專業技能很零散，但如果能透過平台接案，聚合起來就能成為一個強大的「虛擬工作室」。
聽起來有商機。不過，剛才你提到有些VPP計畫可能會出問題，比如電力公司錯誤預測用電量，反而增加其他人的電費。這模式撐得久嗎？
這點Severin Borenstein，一位加州大學柏克萊分校能源研究所的教授，他有提到，如果計畫沒有執行好，確實可能出現這種狀況。但他同時也說，「如果我們做得好，我認為它真的可以帶來好處」，可以幫助電力公司避免昂貴的電網升級，或是緊急限電措施。
所以重點還是在於「怎麼做」。那如果我是普通上班族，這個概念我能怎麼應用到我的工作或生活？
我覺得最直接的，就是「盤點和利用閒置資源」。你上班通勤的路上，是不是有些你平常不會用到的時間或技能？比如你擅長做簡報，或許可以在社群上分享教學，這也是一種「虛擬簡報中心」。或是家裡有些閒置物品，透過二手平台釋出，這就是把「閒置資產」轉化為「虛擬供應鏈」的一部分。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說應用到上班族，會不會有點牽強？這畢竟是電力公司的創新，要怎麼和普通工作搭上關係？
其實我覺得可以從「看待資源的方式」來學習。我們習慣把資源看成是實體的、集中的。但VPP告訴我們，許多小而分散的東西，只要找到對的聚合方式，就能產生意想不到的巨大價值。上班族的工作技能也是這樣，你的零碎技能可能不被重視，但如果能串聯起來，或許能發展出新的副業或專案。
嗯，把「碎片化」的資源重新組合，創造新價值。這個觀點確實值得思考。那要怎麼開始呢？原文有提到怎麼簽約嗎？
有，原文提供了幾個方法。首先，你可以查詢自己的電力公司有沒有相關計畫，搜尋「需求響應」、「尖峰獎勵」、「智能恆溫器獎勵」這些關鍵字。但更常見的是，設備製造商會直接透過他們的App、Email通知你。
設備製造商？所以我的智慧家電或電動車App裡，可能就會跳出這個選項？
對，原文提到，Joseph Vellone，一位電動車VPP公司的執行長，他就說電動車駕駛甚至可以在車廠的App裡，按一個按鈕就註冊了。不過每個計畫支援的設備品牌和類型都有點複雜，像Wi-Fi恆溫器、電動車的廠牌、充電器、甚至電池的品牌和安裝商，都可能影響你是否符合資格。
所以不是每個人想參加都能參加，還有一些限制和地區差異。這點有點實際。那如果我要簽約，需要考慮什麼？
最重要的就是「你能有多少彈性」。原文有提到，你要問自己，願不願意讓公司調整你家裡的設備？比如電動車充一整夜，如果它只需要兩小時，那延遲充電時間可能沒什麼影響。但如果你工作時間很特殊、有照顧家人需求，或是本來就為了省錢而非常節省用電，那電力公司調整你的空調或充電時間，可能就會對你造成不便。
了解了，所以這是一個雙向的選擇。用戶需要評估自己的生活模式，才能決定是否值得參與。
對，這點非常關鍵。就好像也提醒了我們，在做任何商業模式創新時，都需要深入了解用戶的真實需求和彈性程度。